[Music]
and thus another season comes to an end
how has your spring been let me know in
the comment section below normally i'd
be talking about the next season in one
of these videos however i feel that it
would be good to go the second mile to
be a little bit more forward looking
most of us like action anime here so i'd
like to tell you about some of the shows
that i'm personally very excited for
today's list will get me through my top
anticipated action anime of 2022 and
2023
we start with vampire in the garden
the forbidden union between man and
monster is a popular topic in fiction
first studio which brings us vampire in
the garden a new original anime that
looks to expand on this theme even more
it tells of a world where men and
vampires once lived together since then
the world has changed and become more
divided than ever with humanity being
forced to stay behind walls having lost
their homes still some long to return to
that bygone era of harmony the paths
cross of momo a girl who wants nothing
more than to play the violin and find
the vampire queen who once had a heart
for humans when their paths cross what
fate awaits their journey i know i know
let's get those aot jokes out of the way
now it doesn't help the wit is the
studio for this beside that though we
don't have much info about the series as
of now still i see quite a lot to be
excited about vampire in the garden
first off the visuals look absolutely
stunning it surely is pivoting itself to
be one of those classic looking shows if
you get what i mean also i think that
this will be one of those shows that
combine action and drama with a dark
atmosphere not something that you see in
anime too often although shows like
these aren't as rare as i could have
made it sound so if you're up for
something along the lines of vanitas or
pandora hearts in terms of feel you
could go for this once it drops on the
16th of may
we have spriggan as the next entry on
our list
special ops men teaming up to fight each
other over a legendary artifact that's a
great premise to sell and spriggan is an
anime that combines it with some
supernatural elements government
conspiracies and a plot that takes you
all over the world spriggan is not a new
story however this is a modernized
version of an old movie from the 90s it
looks to retell a story through current
technology and i think that the trailer
gives us a good idea of what the show is
all about it's frantic and it's
something that will surely feed your
craving for those high octane action
shows this is probably the show to
recommend to your friends who aren't too
much into anime culture yet it has all
the traits of an action spy flick from
hollywood and it could be a nice getaway
to people who are fond of such films
netflix bringing it over could also mean
that you'll be able to binge the show
when it gets released
we have my hero academia's sixth season
i had to do a double take i remember
when the show first hit the airwaves and
just like that we've now got six seasons
of this thing already i knew back then
that my hero academia was popular but
2016 me didn't expect the show to have
this much longevity then again i should
have if only i had the ability to tell
the future and look at the twists and
turns the stories had since then now
we're on our way to my hero academia's
own war arc with the villains having
been united under shigaraki's banner in
the last season it's time for our heroes
to put up or shut up it's the
culmination of the rise of villain saga
that we've long been waiting for it's
one of the most hyped arcs and i can't
wait to see endeavour and friends go all
out fall 2022 is when we'll get to see
this latest installment with that being
a lot closer than it first sounds my
hero academia fans rejoice
[Music]
next is blades of the guardians
blades of the guardians what never heard
of it i don't blame you after all
instead of being adapted from a japanese
manga blades of the guardians is the
adaptation of a chinese comic series man
wine short with one look at the poster i
know you guys can guess the general gist
the idea of what blades of the guardians
is going to be about it's overall an
honest show in terms of what it brings
to the table swords action an element of
drama in addition i like how blades of
the guardians incorporate some
historical elements with it too it's got
a premise that's common with that of a
samurai traveling to repay his debt
fighting demons along the way in his
battles to protect his family and the
sui dynasty he uncovers secrets that
even he might not come out of unscathed
the traitor also showcases the level of
violence in the series so it's a good
way to gauge if the series will be to
your liking if you like something like
doraro you should definitely consider
this one
now before we continue i want to ask you
a genuine question with what's going on
in the world in your personal life these
days are you feeling down we all know
anime and manga can cheer us up and give
us a reason to strive for another day
but at times i myself can't help but
fall to the pressure and feel down it
can happen to anyone at any time so
that's a good thing we've got today's
sponsor better help better help is an
online service that allows you to link
up with professionally licensed
therapists who are already and waiting
to listen better helps 20 000 plus
therapists cover a wide range of
specialties so you can easily find one
that's tailor-made for your needs and
concerns all you need to do is sign up
answer a questionnaire and the service
will quickly link you to a therapist
within 48 hours it's really convenient
and you can have your talks in a private
environment think something like discord
calls which i'm sure you're familiar
with and if you think things aren't
working out for you you can easily
switch therapists free of charge all you
need to do is to check out the link in
the description or go to
betterhelp.comtube that way you can
avail of a 10 discount in your first
month that's really handy now isn't it
right a bright future awaits you all
thanks to better help
up next we have hell's paradise
is what you'd want from a ninja the
finest member of the clan he gets
betrayed and set for execution however
there's a problem with that this is a
man who just refuses to die literally he
just survived everything seeing this his
executioner instead offers him a chance
for pardon he'll go on a journey to look
for the fabled elixir of life and thus
begins his journey to the island known
as paradise no one who ever steps foot
on the island returns alive and with
perils lurking at every corner
gabimaru's immortality will be put to
the test with the promise of freedom and
a reunion with his family at stake he'll
go through the bowels of hell itself now
here's an adventure series for you
having read the manga i'd say that it's
underrated compared to its peers the
story is well structured and i found it
never running out of steam in the
suspense department if you're up for a
thrilling adventure with well-written
characters perhaps this could be the
show to put on your radar
[Music]
and now we begin our boss rush of action
anime sequels starting off with jiu
jitsu kaizen's second season
jujutsu kaizen short made a name for
itself in the past year didn't it on one
hand i'd say that it's strongly helped
by demon slayer's success but on the
other hand i think that it's just an
unfair assessment after all jujutsu
kaizen is such a great shonen a good
power system immersive storylines
characters that you care about
astonishingly good animation for the
fights these are all the ingredients of
a runaway shonen hit they're all there
and it's a little something that i want
to tell you the next main story arc is
even better than anything we've seen so
far learning about gojo's past is cool
but shibuya arc is where it's at fights
more intense than ever before await i'm
sure that a couple of hearts are going
to be broken it's my favorite arc in the
series so far and i really want to see
how mappa will knock you out of the park
this time
[Applause]
finland saga is also joining in on the
fun too
[Music]
[Applause]
remember my old video where i pegged
villain saga as the best action anime of
2019 it doesn't take a genius to guess
that i'm super excited for its much
awaited sequel vinland saga to me is one
of the most complete action anime out
there it has a good blend of drama
character build up action and emotional
pull to really get me to care however to
those who want to see more action and
adventure the thrills of the first
season i hate to be the bearer of bad
news vineland saga's second season will
feature less of those hype fights as the
story shifts in tone but that doesn't
make it a bad thing think something like
golden garmue further emphasizes my
point of view and saga being such a
complete action anime i'm all in for a
drama heavy season that's full of
character development and emotion if
you're up for something like this
villain saga's second season sure seems
promising
[Music]
then we have mob psycho 100 season
three yep you heard that right mob
psycho is coming back for a third season
but because it's one of the most popular
action anime out there and how a new
season comes out every three years is it
surprising that 2022 will see the return
of mob and friends there have been
rumors going around that the third
season is the grand finale of the series
you know that got me hyped even more
bones will surely do justice this season
and i just can't help but get excited to
see everything culminate in one grand
climax this is an anime getting a
well-deserved third season and my
expectations are sky high i can't wait
to be thrilled and experience the magic
of mob psycho once again it may be sad
to possibly say goodbye to a show that
gave me so many goosebumps and tears but
i'm more than thankful that we have
bones is masterful adaptation to see the
series through
[Music]
as one masterpiece ends another looks to
step up this is chainsaw man
in death one becomes even stronger when
denji finds himself on the wrong side of
the murderous yakuza he finds himself
facing death however his death only
opens the window to a new life being
reborn as someone with the powers of the
chainsaw devil with his new power he
catches the attention of the public
safety bureau who offer him a new job as
a devil hunter now with the promise of a
life that he'd always wanted denji has
become the worst nightmare of the
world's demonic spawns mappa brings us
the upcoming anime adaptation of this
hit series from shonen jump it's dark
it's violent and it's full of black
comedy quite the glorious set of
ingredients for some insane fun right
the thing with chainsaw man is that it's
also serious with some profound
characters all while thematically
looking nothing like a typical shonen
jump series can you feel the hype
already for this one because i sure can
and this is for sure going to be the
major hit of 2022
[Music]
finally we have bleach making its long
awaited return
we finally have a release date folks we
have long gotten confirmation of
bleach's thousand-year blood war are
getting an anime but everyone seems so
mum on the release now we know that fall
2022 is when we'll see the glorious
return of one of the most iconic battle
shonen of the 2000s bleach looks to
adapt the final arc but only time will
tell on how they plan to adapt it it is
a very long arc and i think the pulling
of shaman king just wouldn't do the arc
justice please make this a long runner
again thank you after all it's where so
many secrets and mysteries will be
solved ichigo's origin the ancient
quincy war the soul king all these will
have answers in the grandest arc of
bleach so far being a fan of the series
and someone who's followed the manga all
the way to its conclusion you can bet
i'm excited as hell for this one it's
time to wake up and rise once again
fellow bleach fans
[Music]
[Music]
what do you think of my list then how
does my list compare to yours i'm
excited to hear about the action anime
that you're very excited for so come on
down to the comment section and chime in
or you can just join the official
vinitube discord server for giveaways
and more just follow the link in the
description box everyone's welcome to
drop by and while you're at it why not
also check out my patreon and instagram
too and don't forget to check out our
sponsors better help betterhelp is here
to help and there's no one better to
deal with those mental health problems
thank you once again for watching the
video and i'll see you next time
[Music]